Speaker 1: Let's go to Mike in northeastern
Connecticut. Mike, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: David, thank you for taking my call. I
had a question about ranked choice voting, OK, why
Massachusetts didn't pass that in the last vote.
Speaker 1: Did that not pass in Massachusetts,
I don't remember there are
so many ballot initiatives,
I can't remember all of them. I don't know
why it didn't pass, if that's the case, but
I've spoken about ranked choice voting a
number of times. There's a number of different
configurations of it, single transferable vote
and many others. I think the most important thing
when it comes to ranked choice voting is voters
need to be confident that there is no possible way
that someone who really doesn't have a plurality
of voters wanting them to be the winner
ends up as the winner. And it's sort of like a
mathematical problem, and we've done a number of
interviews on this. There's a number of systems
that ensure that and that accomplish that.
And it's generally speaking a system I'm in favor
of with the caveat that I would like to see ranked
choice voting and public financing of elections
and campaign finance reform because not only
is it important to generate votes for
third parties and additional parties,
it would also be great for the main two parties
not to have such an overwhelming advantage when
it comes to the money. So I think you need
to do both together. I'd also love to see a
national popular vote, and all of these things
together feel like pipe dreams, but they're
the ideal that that I've sort of envisioned.
Speaker 2: Now, do you feel the voters would be
competent enough to fill more a regular ballot?
Speaker 1: I don't know. I mean, we do have a
competence and education problem in the United
States. I'm pretty confident that if people
just get a piece of paper and it says there
are five candidates, rank them one to five
that most voters would be able to do that
correctly. I'm modestly confident in that.
Speaker 2: OK, great. And do you ever
touch on the right to repair that was
another Massachusetts ballot initiative?
Speaker 1: I'm generally speaking in favor of
the right to repair. I've heard the arguments that
right to repair would allow people to get vehicles
fixed or devices fixed by people who aren't
really qualified. But I don't really buy that.
I think you can deal with the qualification in
the certification. So my view is it's basically
a way to monopolize of service and repair
dollars, and I'm in favor of right to repair.
Great. Thank you for taking my
call. My pleasure, Mike, from
northeastern Connecticut. A
lot of interesting stuff there.